hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast sars cove 2
infection update on laboratory diagnosis
i'm susie valdez of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by
lab roots and sponsored by abbott
diagnostics
so let's get started i'd like to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as
many questions as you want at any time
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click the send button if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
simply click on the support tab found at
the top right
of your presentation window or report
your problem by clicking on the ask a
question
box located on the far left of your
screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr claudio galli
associate medical director in the
infectious disease at abbott
diagnostics for a complete biography of
dr golly
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
without further ado dr gali you may now
begin your presentation
welcome sir
good morning or good afternoon everybody
thanks for joining today
our purpose is to review some aspects on
serological testing for cells co2
infection
and actually the best way to start is to
have a look
at the definition that has been issued
quite a few months ago by the who and
based on the definitions you see
there a confirmed case of starscape 2 or
kovid
is a case that is confirmed by
laboratory testing and this
puts of course a huge burden on
laboratories everywhere because this is
a need not just an option
so how do we deal with diagnosis the
first
and foremost thing that people will look
for is viral rna this is recommended
everywhere and it makes a lot of sense
because it gives you an idea if the
microorganisms is indeed there
point is that regardless of the
technique that is used and the
sensitivity
the yield depends a lot about the kind
of samples you are using so the deeper
you go into the respiratory tract
the higher it is the likelihood to find
viral rna
and there is quite a good reason for
that when you compare the yield you get
from mesopharyngeal or throat swabs with
those
you can take from sputum or stool there
is a clear difference
in that almost two logs in medium values
are
date in practice what does this reflect
well the more you go on over the course
of the infection or disease
the least likely it is to have a
positive result
especially if you are taking samples
from as usually is done by
mesopharyngeal swabs
in this experience you see here up to
almost six weeks after the onset of
symptoms the likelihood of having a
positive result
after three weeks is very low if you're
taking
samples from the upper respiratory tract
and this was already well described by a
review paper that appeared
recently on jama in which the authors
pointed out at this
instance as you may see here
two relevant things that we may note on
this summary slide
first infectivity starts earlier than
symptoms
and this of course is very relevant
because it
justifies the rapid spread defection
and the high contagiousness of these
infections compared to other similar
ones such as the former stars
that we did experience so many years ago
the second fact is that indeed the viral
isolation
may be attained only for a limited
period of time
actually the first week or a little bit
more of course this is a scheme
does not pretend to be exhaustive on all
possibilities that you will encounter in
clinical practice
but what is usually done so testing for
rna yields different results according
to the source of samples as we have seen
but
regardless of that you may note that
when you reach this point it is around
three weeks after infection
it is even less likely than before to to
attain a positive result
and at the same time antibody response
to that infection
appears more or less in this period we
will be more precise a little bit later
and so by coupling the rna detection
and the antibody detection it is
possible
actually to help in diagnosing the
infection much
better than relying on pcr or rna
testing alone
and this as we have noticed is even
recommended
now how may you do that one possible
solution
is use this kind of assay this comes
from above diagnostics is an
assay for specific igg to source co2
and it's targeting a recombinant antigen
from the nucleocapsid region of the
virus so there are several
topics to deal with let's start with the
target selection you see here
as you know the most immunodominant
regions
are the spike and the nucleic acid ones
and acids may target
one or the other according to which is
the preferred need
so having selected the nucleocapsid was
based on the fact that during infection
nuclear capacitors are usually expressed
to a higher yield compared to spy
and as a consequence the antibody
response towards nuclear capital
and capsule tends to appear earlier and
possibly stronger
you see here i mean immunocompromised
patients
and here on immune competent patients
how it may happen
and you may have even a better glimpse
if you look at this series of patients
that have been assayed
by an assay directed against the nucleic
acid or against the spike
rbd domain on the same scale of
intensity of the result you can see that
the anti
and bigg appear general earlier and
attain higher levels and
we have another example here another
thing you may note is that in severe
cases such as those
the response tends to be stronger
whereas in
mild cases depends to be weaker and also
possibly delayed on time
and this is something we will deal with
near the end of our presentation today
the other issue of course is
establishing the positive agreement or
sensitivity if you wish of any given
assay
in the case of the architect
saskatchewan igg this has been done in
the validation by
taking a cohort of patients that have
been tested
in a very early phase a little bit later
so until two weeks after the onset
and then after two weeks or more the
data you will find in the insert
give these figures but those figures do
come with a confidence interval because
as you know very well
100 will never exist in medicine or in
biology so everything
should be framed into a very specific
confidence interval
and we have another demonstration of
that that comes from real practice
when the authors of this paper checked
their population which was quite large
because they took samples for more than
400 patients
and they compared the positivity rate by
that assay
with the time after the onset of
symptoms they basically found the same
values that we have seen before with an
increase over time
if you wish quite surprisingly they did
find antibodies already
in 50 of the population after just one
week
and then when they compared the results
not just to the days after the onset but
the first positive pcr the yield was
even higher
and this is logical because of course
pcr testing
happens after the onset of symptoms so
actually
the leg here is about three four days
and this is why
after two weeks they see they've seen a
complete concordance of results
so as it seems the sensitivity in the
early stages
is quite good and so it will allow to
increase the diagnostic yield when
rna testing is not positive or is not
feasible
the other big topic to deal with
especially
now and the peak of the epidemics has
been regen passed away in many countries
is specificity specificity and negative
agreement may be looked at
differently so you may take on samples
with potentially interfering conditions
which is a classic in laboratory
medicine
you may take samples from other
respiratory illnesses
possibly similar to the one we are
dealing with
or you may take on the samples that have
been collected in the pre-combined era
and this is a true specificity because
of course
since the virus was not circulating at
that time
those samples should come up negative
and this is the value
that has been checked over the
validation of the assay
but even in this case we do have
external evidences
first of all in the validation process
we were not able to assess the eventful
cross-reactivity to
other coronaviruses because those
samples are quite rare
and those were not available for the
valid internal validation
but as of now we already have six
different
external and independent evidences that
check at this
and all of those confirm that this assay
does not resent
from the the testing by other
coronaviruses so all those
almost 60 samples come up negative
on the other side if you want to check
the classical specificity on the
pre-covered samples we still have
the paper we have dealt with before the
first published independent evidence
and in this case the authors did attain
even a higher level of specificity
same indication as we said before uh
concerning sensitivity
every value you will look at in any
paper
should also be accompanied by confidence
interval so in 99.6 99.9
is more or less the same because even if
the cohort is with a year this is not an
absolute value
the other valuable information we get
out of that
is the distribution of the negative
results as you know
an essay may be more or less robust
depending on how
the results are distributed and the more
the negatives are far away from the
threshold area
the better it is because it will
guarantee against
shifts in specificity according to
external variables
you see that in this experience they
were just a dozen samples so that is
one out of 100 of a hundred of the
population that went above this level
and very few that were across this
critical area around the cut-off this
means
that the essay is very robust and the
specificity attained
would be more or less the same
regardless of when you take out testing
and this is confirmed also by another
evidence that is just in preprint now
this combines the detection according to
the weeks after the onset you see here
on the left
and the specificity of another cohort
very similar
and you see that the distribution is the
same the specificity
is 99.8 percent and again there is just
one sample that is across the cutoff
area which is this dotted line
why i'm putting pushing so much on
specificity
this is important because in this kind
of testing we do not have a confirmation
available yet
so you do have a positive result by any
given assay and that's it
you may refer to some recent
recommendation from the cdc to do some
orthogonal testing that is using a very
sensitive assay before
beforehand on the first pass and then
having a second assay
to increase the predictive value and the
predictive value
indeed depends as you know on the
specificity and on the prevalence
so the lower the prevalence the lower
will be the predictive value and this
is an example of that if you take in
account this kind of population with an
estimated pretest probability of 3
percent
and you use an assay that has least
level of specificity
which may be considered good in
diagnostics in general well in this case
actually the predictive value is very
low so you have more false positive than
true positives
if you increase specificity to 99 it's
definitely better
but still one out of four will be a
false positive not because the assay is
not specific
but because the population has not such
a huge prevalence
and if you increase that to a value that
is the one actually attained or or even
better
by the architect assay you have this
kind of positive prediction
if you want to have an actual figure on
the study i mentioned before they did a
population survey in boys idaho
find this kind of prevalence very low
but since their specificity was 99.9
then in that instance even with a very
low prevalence the predictive value
would have been
almost 95 percent which is very hard to
attain by the way
and this has become increasingly
relevant that the more we go on the more
we will see
antibiotic testing in asymptomatic
populations
and in people that possibly did not have
any link
clear epidemiological link what about
then the sequence of the appearance of
biomarkers we have seen that before in
another slide this is more schematic
it's divided for convenience in
incubation early
acute late acute and convalescence
the sequence should be as such viral rna
viral antigen if feasible okay a little
less sensitive
then usually you have the igm response
and then the igg response the difference
is that this response
will last much less and we will see data
on that
whereas the igg response will peak later
and stay on for a long while
how long a while we don't know yet
hopefully it will be lasting long enough
to guarantee some sort of protection
but this is still to be determined and
uncertain
this is in theory what happens in
practice
with the sars curve 2 infection well we
do have
data that more or less are concorded in
that
different observation have a lot to the
conclusion that indeed the igm and the
igg response to this infection
are pretty much alike as far as the time
of onset is concerned
you see here that the days relative to
the positive pcr for igm or igg are more
or less the same
each colored line represents a patient
if you wish we may have a more easy to
look at
slide here in which you see the
difference is
some cases that digital convert earlier
for igm
and earlier by igg which may seem absurd
but it does
happen in this infection and it is not
so infrequent
if you wish to have a more comprehensive
picture we may revert to this kind
of evidence that has been generated on
quite a huge cohort of patients
this is the igm line that raises over
time
and peaks at about 90 percent after
three weeks the igg line
peaks around a hundred percent at the
same time
and if you add the igg to the ibm
response actually the gain is minimal if
any
so you attain the same level of
sensitivity
but there is still a difference if you
wish you may note that
on the thoughts here so let's say that
you're testing at this point
around two weeks you have a maximum
likelihood to find
the patient positive for igg than for
igm but in some instances
you may see igm coming first another
evidence still on a quite huge cohort
brings up the same kind of results you
see here that a positive race for igm
and igg showed some 10 difference
cumulatively
and this happened more both in our tpc
are positive
and negative infections of different
phases of the disease
or infection so overall it looks like a
good
assay for igg will yield a very good
sensitivity
regardless of the detection of igm but
igm may be still
relevant if you are able to discriminate
the two
answers of the two responses as you will
see
soon first a thing that may happen
and indeed has been demonstrated is that
the level of reactivity to igg
and ign may be different according to
the severity of the disease
this is indeed more evident for the igg
response
especially in the early stages you see
here in this other independent
experience that igg
levels attained over the first couple of
weeks
were definitely higher significantly
higher in patients
having a more severe disease this was
not such apparent
later on and for igm this did not happen
so
possibly patients that have a severe
disease
do raise a stronger igg response to the
viral infection
and over time by the way the persistence
is quite different we have seen that in
the scheme
that we proposed before uh getting into
details
of igm and igg you see here an igg
course
with the levels that are still quite
high this is an arbitrary unit by
another assay so
if you reach this point that is many
weeks after the onset
56 days you still have quite high levels
but if you go to the igm in the same
cohort
first of all we'll note that the levels
are much more variable
and second when you reach this point
that is 56 days after the onset
almost two full months after the igm
levels are
usually not detectable you have
exceptions but on average
the igm wins out it is not readily
detectable so
if you're able to test for both igg and
igm you may combine different results
and get also an idea on how recent the
infection has been
another thing that people would like to
do is what happened
if i test during an outbreak people that
maybe
do not have symptoms and this has been
carried out to our attention by this
recent
experience a testing carried out on an
aircraft carrier by the u.s navy where
they experienced an outbreak
and they did find that indeed 60 percent
of the population young adult population
here at reactive antibodies
and 59 of those already had
neutralizing antibodies at the time of
specimen collection
when one fifth that those symptoms
and the preventive measures reduce the
risk of infection again the the
relevance of preventive measures barrier
methods and distancing
is to be continually enforced but you
see here mentioned in the neutralizing
antibodies and this is another very
interesting topic
i think we need a word of clarity about
that everybody
has seen papers or wrappers about
neutralizing antibodies neutralizing
activity
immunity and so forth let's try
and sort it out the presence of
neutralizing antibodies
in the majority of people here is a
promising
indicator of at least short-term
immunity
this is very wise at least short-term
immunity we still do not
know about the long-term immunity this
is a goal
this is a target this is what vaccine
design is aimed to
but for the time being we cannot state
anything
about the long-term immunity especially
just by testing for antibodies
and this is why there is a difference
between binding and neutralizing
antibodies in that
all assays that are used
are now are testing for binding
antibodies
even if they target the spike region the
rpd domain or whatever they will not
detect the neutralizing activity okay
they may be related and indeed will be
related
to neutralizing activity but that's it
if you want to check in neutralizing
activity
you have to run viral testing
so in order to find a functional ability
of antibodies to prevent infection
you must revert either to virus
neutralization or to
micro neutralization and both techniques
require a viral culture require bsl
three level laboratories and
quite long to do to be performed an
alternative may be
to use a pseudo-virus neutralization
test with recombinant viruses
and this may be done in lab in labs with
the lower level of security but this
is different from this what people would
like to see
is any degree of concordance of
correlation between the binding antibody
detection
and the neutralization activity and
indeed there are a few evidences on that
that we may
share so the point of having a
correlation between eliza races and
neutralizing activity has been raised
and demonstrated in quite a few
evidences and independent papers in this
one for
example all those were able to find a
direct correlation to a high degree
between reactivity to the nucleocapsid
or a receptor binding domain or as
antigen in general and the 50 inhibition
of viral
culture and the same at the 90 percent
inhibition
and this may be surprising because the
antibodies raised towards the
nucleocapsid are not neutralized in
their definition
so this just means that a strong
antibody response
is anyhow correlated to the neutralizing
activity of that sample or that patient
and this was also demonstrated in
another study and in a couple other ones
and if you wish you may go to a direct
evidence
concerning the arbit assay by two
different levels of testing
this has been on in a very recent paper
by finnish authors
in which they are certain the
concordance between a neutralizing
activity
and a positivity for igg antibody
checked by different assays you see we
are dealing with this one
in this specific case and out of all
samples that did show neutralizing
activity
the assay was positive in 80 which is
higher
compared to the other assays but even
more interesting if you wish
is what we have seen in another
experience that has been recently made
available
this has been raised by a collaboration
between the san francisco university and
apple r d and on this cohort of patient
you see on the top part of the slide the
circumversion from different patients
immunocompetent and immune compromised
with
the time span between 4 and 25 26 days
from the onset and the median
or 11 days on the bottom part you see
the rays of neutralizing antibody
activity
assessed by pseudo-virus entry
inhibition which is the third method we
have mentioned earlier
and you see that the time lag is the
same and the median
time is the same as well and this has
been confirmed also as far as the
igm reactivity is is concerned you see
that the time lag
is almost identical it may start earlier
in a few instances here
the median is the same and of course
this is again the same
so what's the general meaning of this
kind of experiment which is
that now pretty unique the first thing
that we may observe is that indeed the
neutralizing capacity
of every patient may start as early as a
few days after onset
this is not a fully neutralizing
activity
but it is something that happens and
increases over time you see that over
the time span of three weeks
these neutralizing activity is
demonstrated in almost 100 percent
of patients with an increasing titer at
the same time
also the levels of igm and igg are
raising so we are going back
to the original observation in which we
have hinted
that a good and strong serological
response
by any assay so even by a nucleocapsid
targeting
assay will relate to the neutralizing
activity
then of course we cannot stretch it to
demonstrate that neutralizing just by
testing for binding antibodies
but it gives a justification on the
correlation we may find in different
experiments
so if you want to conclude on the
different combinations you have here
assuming that you have this kind of time
course in which
rna will fade away earlier then igm
and then that will be versus longer you
may have this different combination of
results if you test for both rna
usually by pcr and for igm and igg
separately which will allow to time
better the infection
you have all the different combinations
you see here
two others may be looked at more careful
this is the one the last one is the one
that will be attained the more we go on
testing
on a symptomatic population and doing
population surveys so
more and more cases will be positive
just for igg and then we may have also
the instance in which only the igm
is positive so this should be deemed as
a recent infection with a negative
pcr result by any given cause timing
pre-analyticals whatever but it may also
be due to a false positive igm result
and you know that usually
testing for igm is let's say more
delegate than testing for igg
but here again we do have some data to
show
that the prototype assay from about igm
to source code 2 that was used in this
paper
did show a very good specificity as well
i would say at the same level as the agm
iggy sa we have seen before and again
you see a good distribution
and very few samples around the
threshold so this is promising in the
sense
of what we have seen before that is
combining
testing separately for igg and ign
then if you wish what is antibody
testing useful for
in general well it may tell you
something
it may tell you that a person has been
infected
in the past we don't know how much in
the past until we test separately for
igg and ign
if both are positive well the infection
is very recent
if the igm is negative igg is positive
it is a more distant infection at least
several weeks you have seen
the graph with the igm reactivity that
appears to
be not present anymore after a couple of
months
but at the same time we should be aware
about what antibody testing cannot tell
you
it cannot tell you if the person has
recovered because it does not preclude
persistent infection the recovery is
usually
established by repeat testing for rna
this is the rule of thumb as of now
it may not tell the real antibody level
we do know that our assets they do
express results in arbitrary units but
at least according to the cdc and this
makes a lot of sense to me as well
the assets at best are semi-quantitative
there is no standard unit
there is no reference so speaking about
quantitation of antibodies a little bit
too early
at the same time as we have seen before
we have binding antibody assays
we cannot tell it right away any kind of
serology you have available now if the
antibodies are really neutralizing you
need
a specific neutralization assay to be
performed
we may anticipate that this will not
last for a long time eventually we will
have also
assays we will detect specifically
neutralizing antibodies but not now
then as a last part i would like to
present you some scenarios that may
occur
if we assume that in case with symptoms
or at high rates we are testing
for rna plus serology according to the
different environments according to the
different
rules you may have this combination of
results
and quite obviously if you just have a
positive for rna this is an early stage
of infection
unless the person is immunocompromised
or
as we have seen before if the person has
very mild of no
symptoms but this is contradictory to
the title of the slide
and in that case the immune response the
humeral immune response may be delayed
if you are both positive well in this
case
this is an infection with immunity
development but not
resolved this looks result late stage of
infection or previously immune
if diseased with another kind of disease
but since we are dealing with
symptomatic or high risk
it would be advisable to check again for
rna
and the same comes if you are dealing
with a person that happens to be
negative about
rna and serology the rule of thumb
should be this person is naive to the
infection but again
due to the pre-testing probability here
and to the environment
it should be better to repeat testing in
this scenario
now let's consider exactly the same
combination in this different scenario
in which the population is completely
different because it's a symptomatic
and at low risk of course the
combinations are the same but in this
instance
compared to this instance okay the
combination is the same but the
population is not so in this case
it is extremely likely that we have a
status of immunity
which does not mean protection remember
this please
this is immune response to the infection
does not equal
protection or immunity certificate or
whatsoever
and again on the last instance in which
both are negative
usually you may deem that this person is
naive to the infection this is
not a symptomatic high risk this is a
symptomatic low risk so even the
interpretation
of the results of any given combination
of assays
will depend a lot upon the environment
on which testing is taken
then another possibility is that by any
given reason
you just start by serology this usually
cannot be done of course to diagnose but
this will be good
if you want to do a prevalence study if
you want to a certain which has been
the actual diffusion of the infection in
a given population if you remember the
case of the
u.s aircraft carrier in that case you
have serology first
a double check here negative positive
and then what you do next
again there is no rule but you may
consider
testing for rna here in order to be sure
that the person is not still infected
and if not of course this person is
immune with the same indication as
before
that is immune where his immune response
to infection does not equal protection
if you have a negative and you want to
be absolutely sure
just out of precaution you may retest
after a couple
of weeks and it is still negative it's a
naive if it
comes positive it could be a window here
and then you may consider testing for
rna but again
what you do and how you do that depends
a lot on the environment
of the eventful recommendation and
practices so
this is just if you wish something you
may discuss
with your colleagues and peers then what
if antibody tests are negative
and this will become more and more
frequent the more we go on in testing
the most easy interpretation is that the
person is nailed to the infection
has not been infected yet and possibly
will never be hopefully
but you may also have a person that is
tested
during the very early phases of
infection so antibodies have
not been raised yet we have seen cases
in which
the body response is pretty frequent in
the early stages but this is not common
especially if people have very few
symptoms
then you may consider also the fact
that many people will encounter the
virus and clear the virus
just by the innate t-cell response so in
this
instance antibodies will not be raised
and the person will not be detected by
by simple antibody testing it
encountered the virus
did not get the disease result infection
just by natural immunity or
and this will become more and more
frequent the person was infected
had some sort of active infection so
mounted an antibody response
but the levels are constantly or for a
long time
below the limit of detection of any
given assay
again it depends so much on the kind of
population
and then the kind of symptoms if any
that the person may have
so a word of caution on that doesn't
matter
what you have seen or you what you may
read on papers that are dealing with
severely ill population
when you're testing population with less
disease severity
or no severity at all it could happen
and there have been records
about people being constantly positive
or positive for a long time for rna
without a detectable antibody response
so this
is the limitation and if you wish to
conclude
it does not tell a hundred percent that
the person is acceptable so even by the
best
possible essay for antibodies for to
source code two
the negative predictive value will never
be a hundred percent
but nevertheless there is utility in
testing for antibodies
since we are targeting the about igg
assay
how may we use that well first of all a
date in the etiological diagnosis when
on probable cases so symptoms plus
epidemiological or anamastic evidence
when rna testing is negative or cannot
be performed
and if patients are presenting after 9
to 14 days from the onset that this is
what
the cdc has very recently indicated in
their interim guidelines
second to evaluate the number of people
exposed to starscope too
and this would be very useful on to us
to assert in the prevalence
and if you wish also the incidents
because if you take the same cohort
and test the cohort over time and we do
know that our research project same in a
test
you may find also the new cases that
will become positive for antibodies
and this will allow to estimate the
incidence
so overall testing for antibodies by
this assay
may allow to allocate resources and also
to plan for future interventions
that's it for today thanks so much for
your attention
thank you dr golly for that informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions
as we have time for so let's take a look
at our questions coming in right now
dr golly which role may antibody
testing have in the gnosis of covid19
and
sars code 2 infection
that this is a very relevant question
thank you for posing that
as you know according to the indication
we got from the w2 and the cdc as well
antibody testing can support or aid
diagnosis of infection and disease
whenever viral dna yields a negative
result or cannot be performed
with a limitation is that sampling
occurring before 14 days may limit the
validity of serology
on the other side antibody testing is a
classical measure to evaluate prevalence
of any given infection
and this has already been considered in
some countries when zero prevalence or
zero surveillance studies have already
been started
thank you for that and why has the
abbott activity
not been verified on other coronal
viruses different
from stars code two
well yes this is a valid question but at
the time of the asset validation we did
not have this capability
since soft samples are not easily
available
nevertheless the careful selection of
the n-region sequences
in our assay resulted in a very good
specificity as we have seen
by the way six independent studies so
far have confirmed that there is a lack
of gross reactivity to other
coronaviruses so
we are pretty confident about that
thank you dr gully and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in
secretary have there been reports of
patients
who tested negative for igg antibodies
more than two weeks after the onset of
coping 19 disease yes indeed
this has been observed by different
independent studies
part of those cases may be explained by
host related factors such as a
transient or prolonged status of immune
deficiency
as an example transplant recipients more
in general
patients who experience a mild disease
have usually later
and less sustained antibody response and
finally you must remember
that disease onset is the subjective
estimate and there
may be quite the difference between the
actual onset
and what is reported by any given
patient
thank you dr golly and have there been
concerns on a widespread use of antibody
testing
due to perceived lack in specificity
actually this concern was here initially
due to the relatively poor performance
of some essays that then we may be
available soon after the start of the
pandemics
none of those by the way were on
automated platforms such as the one
we have described today the assays on
automated platforms including the one
from abbot
have a much higher specificity and that
shall guarantee as we have seen
a good positive predictive value even if
the population tested as a low
prevalence
thank you dr and we have time for one
more question
why did abbott choose to develop an
assay for igg
instead of an assay for total antibodies
good question thank you but the date
available at the time the answer had
been developed and
those have been also confirmed later by
other studies
including those performed with the
abbott assay
i've shown that in this infection in
starscript to infection the difference
in circumversion
between igg and igm is minimal and in
many instances there is no difference at
all or igg
are detectable even earlier than a
specific igm
also the igg response is usually looked
for in syrup prevalence surveys since it
lasts
longer by the way an igm assay from
abbott will be available a few weeks
from now
so being able to discriminate an igm
from an igg response will allow a better
staging of the infection and may be
especially useful
when rna testing gives a negative result
thank you again dr golly for your
presentation today would you like
do would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience today
i would be delighted to first of all i
thank again everybody would join today
and i do hope that this was easy useful
and also will stimulate discussion
because this is
a field that is moving so fast you know
so the knowledge we have reached up to
now is not enough
especially on the kinetics and the
antibodies and the internalizing
response
and we hope to have further evidences to
share with you very soon
thank you and before we go i want to
thank the audience for joining us for
today
and for their interesting questions and
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and i'd also like to thank you again dr
claudio golly for this time today and
for your important research
i'd also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor
abbott diagnostics for underwriting
today's educational webcast
this webinar is available for unlimited
on-demand
viewing through july 6 2020.
thank you bye